hey folks it's the middle of summer but
if you're a hearthstone fan the fun is
just beginning
I'm Peter Brown here today with dead
Cossack from Blizzard League mission
designer on hearthstone thank you for
coming in hello thanks for having us
yeah we're gonna chat about the booms
day project it's a new set of cards come
in a hearthstone and we're gonna reveal
a new one today as well before we get to
that Dave can you give me a quick
rundown on what these sort of the theme
of the booms this this expansion this is
all about science it's all about mad
science it's all about crazy scientists
and we want the players to feel like mad
scientist as well like really combining
and experimenting with different
mechanics and so are our designers have
gone just like over-the-top with just
some really weird cards we don't even
know how people are gonna use them but
we're gonna see a lot of scientists out
there experimenting with some weird
effects and weird things to do it is the
booms day project the nefaria
supervillain dr. boom has assembled 8 of
the World of Warcraft's most nefarious
and morally flexible scientists to
research along the lines of the 9
hearthstone classes different kind of
crazy things to do it's a really
experimental set for us and I think
it'll be really experimental for players
on I'm really excited to see what people
come up with well I think when the first
ingredients of the experiment we're
ready to talk about today so what is the
card that you've brought to child yeah
well we are here to unveil the shrink
ray correct all right so what does this
card do exactly yeah the shrink ray this
this is a spell that changes the attack
and health of all minions friendly an
enemy all all minions all support across
the board to one one makes everybody
yeah but it's a paladin card and it's
interesting because often you know we
put cards and sets that have some
utility some value for players even if
we don't necessarily know what kind of
decks people are build with it so so the
shrink-ray is really for a control
paladin there's not a whole lot of
control paladin archetypes out there but
if that's some sort of in the mid game
when things are getting hot and heavy
they can kind of control the board
change everything yeah yeah yeah tamp it
down so you got a lot of threats coming
down at you everybody gets small right
it doesn't quite clear the board but you
know it combo isn't nice with other
cards tundra rhino is an interesting
card that you can play right afterwards
a tundra Rhino destroys a random small
minion on the other side of the board
and so that's nice you can kind of
follow up and immediately get rid of one
there's a card called mossy horror from
the which would expansion and the mossy
horror I don't think you played on the
same turn but you can play it on follow
up turn and it destroys any minion with
an attack of less than two gotcha
I love the fantasy of that because it's
kind of like the Paladin shrinks
everybody in the room and then this
giant monster comes in who steps on
everybody right yeah yeah so it's a fun
card we don't know necessarily what
people are gonna do with it right yeah a
lot of lot of uses actually my favorite
trick there are eggs that you can play
and eggs are often zero attack minions
that hatch or something there's a devil
soar egg that death rattle hatches into
a 5 5 million so pretty cool but it's
hard to kind of get rid of your egg
because it can't attack that's where the
shrink right comes in shrink right
actually makes your egg 1/1 now can
start attacking people when you can
sacrifice your egg and then you get a
big dinosaur so there's kind of really
clever ways to play this card that it's
what the expansion is about really is
finding mechanics and then using them in
unexpected ways so we're curious to see
what I have paladins are gonna do with
the mighty science power of the
shrink-ray it sounds like even as
designers you're finding like strange
ways to use this card yeah how long does
it take to really you know when you have
a card like this taken from the
conceptual phase to saying like yeah you
know this fits we're gonna learn to put
the same yeah it's funny we actually
have two different teams on the
hearthstone design team we have what we
call the initial design team
and the final design team and the
initial design team comes up with crazy
crazy cards some hundreds of cards per
set crazy cards and they kind of try and
figure out what is fun or gang and
narrow it down to what they think is
said it's gonna be and then we pass it
over to final design who kind of gives
it the sniff test and make sure that
this card won't break the game and we
try like sometimes I feel like initial
design they try and break the game as
much as they can get away with and then
final design has to come in and say like
what what are we gonna do yeah and sort
of make sure everything fits together
and it comes together so yeah that
process it takes a few months we're
always working a few months ahead for
the next the next expansion what has
been unique about the development of the
brooms day projects um booms a project
has some really fun mechanics like I
said we really wanted players to
experiment so we did things like we have
legendary spells in this expansion so a
legendary card you can only have one of
in your deck and so that lets us do
spells that do weird weird things that
we would never be able to do with spells
before so I Meyers unstable element is
one of the ones we revealed in the
announcement video Meyers unstable
element it's a spell that draws the rest
of your deck like all right which of
course you can only have only ten cards
so sometimes it'll just burn your whole
deck play it's crazy it's a crazy card
obviously you wouldn't want two of them
in your deck that would be weird that'd
be worthless yeah so but it's a perfect
legendary spell we really challenged
ourselves with this set to come up with
mechanics there like that's weird
what are people gonna do with I don't
know way to know what's gonna happen
science it'll turn out it'll turn out
great yeah so you know we definitely
we've experimented quite a bit with this
set another mechanic that I think is
really fun for players to experiment
with is we have magnetic minions so you
know mechs robots it's a really fun
party science so we have mechs in the
game that are magnetic and what magnetic
means is you can keep them in your hand
and you can play them as they are they
are perfectly playable mech but if
they're magnetic you can also stick it
on to an existing mech bolster their
strengths that's exactly it becomes like
a buff so if they're out there on the
board and maybe they're ready to attack
you can take this other mech and glom it
on their stick them together and then
you have a super mech
they can attack a lot of fun we don't
know what people are gonna do with that
but you get to do feel like a scientist
experimenting like you have it in your
hand what am I gonna do with this you
know when do I use it how do I play it
we don't even know and that's what is so
exciting about this release when the
booms Day project hits with no idea what
people are gonna do
so shrink-ray obviously sounds very
exciting yeah other cards you mentioned
as well what is just one more example
from the booms a project that you're
personally there's so many there's so
many things going on so you know dr.
boom has assembled scientists for all
the different classes and I think one of
my favorites is probably in the druid
Lab and this is some we struggle with
like what are droids doing Howard druids
do mad science and so our druid
scientist is the legendary libidinous
fluke - hello - yeah so he is a 3/4
minion and he can be it makes it kind of
this big pile of green goo and he
becomes a copy of the last minute play a
3/4 copy the last mini D plays maybe
hold onto him until you're ready to put
some yeah I guess has a really powerful
effect powerful death rattle something
out comes Floop yeah and that's a fun
card it was really know what players are
gonna do with Floop and it'll be an
interesting card not just this set but
you know all the sets for the rest of
the season right they come out who knows
what Floop is gonna do that crazy druid
so when complainers expect to actually
experiment with the new brooms April
courts August 7th the booms Day project
will hit the world and look out that's
right around the corner that's right
around the corner yeah the experiments
will begin yeah yeah yeah that's a lot
of fun and this that's just full of fun
things that we don't know what's gonna
happen
thanks so much Dave for coming by today
we just revealed the shrink-ray card
coming to hearthstone soon as part of
the booths a project there are more card
reveals on the way so stay tuned of
GameSpot as we report on those as those
announcements are made take care
you
[Music]